the Sultana is an all-new cat stronghold
as a historical figure she was a
Sultan's Widow could have a crucial role
after his death during the seventh
crusade against Egypt interstellar -
she's cast as sort of world weary
freedom fighter which actually ties into
one of game's big themes for us we
always get historical accuracy correct
and strong games but in cristela - we're
doing our best to portray the era of
bosses they really were during the
Crusades which is you know as freedom
fighters against foreign invasion I mean
it certainly a factory accuracy there
and we've got the parrot walls and
different troop types that are Saturday
night but it's also really important to
convey that the Crusaders were
definitely the bad guys in this story
you know however lovable we try and make
rich of the lineup so the Sultana will
not make life easy for you she repairs
the use of specialized units like the
assassin to attack so our whole numbers
may be fewer than other Lords the troop
she does recruit are significantly more
deadly her castle economy is geared
towards producing gold to recruit these
troops so she'll protect buildings like
the mercenary camp and you know others
quite fiercely I bet on a Calif that
sometimes castle may not look heavily
fortified but she'll have plenty of
assassins in hiding waiting to kill your
units as the answer so looks can be
deceiving
there's a partner can attack at any time
during a match because the timings of
her attacks are slightly unpredictable
it's usually a good idea pair protect as
early on as possible when she does
attach tends to use distractions the
means of catch near off guard
the father will attack with multiple
squads of troops distracting you with
one more flanking from behind with
another to defend against salt I'll need
lots and lots of archers as her
preferred method of attack is to
assassins she may send these assassins
in on their own you know in which case
she's hoping to scale your walls slit
bio defences undetected using the
assassins camouflage ability and kill
your lord before you vanilla's going on
and to counter this you'll need lots of
archers placed even in or on your walls
and open towers as well to give them the
best sort of sight and range advantage
possible another method of attack for
the Sultana is to use siege equipment to
blast all your walls for rushing and
assassins to deliver the killing blow
one good way to avoid this is to have a
squad of archers behind the walls and
use their arrow volubility to shoot
around the siege equipment hopefully
killing any
Assasin's that may be lurking in the
shadows since our partners economy is
based around gold production and the
recruitment of special units the best
way to launch seeds by targeting the
buildings that produce these units
you'll want to make your first line of
attack either cheap units like the
comics or slaves and to use them as
cannon fodder
or use archers to take out the assassins
before they reach your troops once
you've got through their castle walls
and her initial layer of attack you want
to look out for what units she has and
take advantage of her low number of
troops if the Sultana has recruited
assassin ignites for example put your
Piper at the front and take them out
with their digging ability if she's
recruited well in dervishes put forward
lots of heavily armoured troops like
maybe some Templar knights and take them
out before they decimate your weaker
troops like the archers if you can deal
with their special units the sultanas
castle is essentially yours for the
taking